This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Some years ago, I got a talking with an investor. By his own account, he was a 1%er. Like many other successful Americans before him, he had overcome many challenges growing up. And then he told me about the one thing in his life that made him sad. His kids. They were sweet and smart, but they lacked
这里是《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。几年前，我曾与一位投资者交谈。据他自己所说，他是那1%的富人阶层。和许多早期的成功美国人一样，他在成长过程中克服了许多挑战。随后，他向我倾诉了他生活中最令他伤心的一件事。他的孩子们。他们既贴心又聪明，但他们缺乏
drive. They had led easy lives, he told me. They didn't have the same hunger that had made him successful. I've heard variations of the same story over the years. People who have come through adversity will invariably tell you that their adversity played a central role in their success. This idea that hard times make us stronger has been touted so often and by so many people that we rarely stop to ask ourselves, is there any truth to the story? This week on Hidden Brain, we explore whether adversity is the secret sauce of success. Iranda Jaya Vikrama grew up in Sri Lanka while a civil war raged in that country. When he was 21, he moved to the United States to study.
进取心。他告诉我，他们过着安逸的生活。他们没有那种曾让他取得成功的渴望。这些年来，我听过这个故事的各种版本。经历过逆境的人总是会告诉你，逆境在他们的成功中发挥了核心作用。这种“艰难困苦能让我们变得更强大”的观点被太多人、太频繁地宣扬，以至于我们很少停下来问问自己：这个说法到底有没有道理？本周的《隐形大脑》节目中，我们探讨逆境是否是成功的秘诀。伊兰达·贾亚维克拉马在斯里兰卡内战肆虐的环境中长大。21岁时，他搬到了美国求学。
Soon after his arrival, Iranda began to notice that Americans had a way of thinking about adversity and suffering that was new to him. It became the start of a lifelong exploration. Today, as a psychologist at Wake Forest University, Aranda is asking a question that is increasingly relevant in many parts of the world. What happens to people as they go through terrible times and what advice can science give them about the best path forward? Aranda Jaiwekrama, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Aranda, you arrived in the, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me.
刚到美国不久，伊兰达就开始注意到，美国人看待逆境和苦难的方式对流落异乡的他来说十分新颖。这成为了他一生探索的起点。如今，作为维克Forest大学的心理学家，阿兰达正在提出一个在世界许多地方日益相关的问题。人们在经历可怕的时期时会发生什么？科学能为他们指出前进的最佳道路提供什么建议？阿兰达·贾亚维克拉马，欢迎来到《隐形大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来。阿兰达，你来到...欢迎来到《隐形大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来。
Eranda, you arrived in the United States shortly before the 9-11 attacks. And a few weeks after the attacks, New York's mayor Rudy Giuliani gave a speech at the United Nations. This massive attack was intended to break our spirit. Has not done that. It's made us stronger, more determined and more resolved. So there was a theme in speeches like this that jumped out at your under. You felt it reflected a particularly American way of thinking about trauma. What did you hear?
埃兰达，你在9·11袭击发生前不久来到了美国。袭击发生几周后，纽约市长鲁迪·朱利安尼在联合国发表了演讲。这次大规模袭击旨在摧毁我们的精神。但它没有做到这一点。它让我们变得更强大、更坚定、更有决心。因此，这类演讲中有一个主题非常触动你，埃兰达。你觉得它反映了一种特别美国式的创伤思考方式。你听到了什么？
One thing that I remember being struck by was this idea that, well, this bad thing has happened, but something good is going to come out of it. We're absolutely determined that something good is going to come out of it. And I remember thinking, well, that's interesting, because the first thing you typically want to do is make sure you can manage with the impact of that bad thing. And maybe in the wake of what's happened, try and return to where you were before, or return to a baseline.
我记得让我印象深刻的一点是这种观点，即：好吧，这件坏事发生了，但好事将从中诞生。我们绝对坚信，好事一定会从中诞生。我当时想，这很有趣，因为你通常想做的第一件事，是确保自己能够应对这件坏事带来的冲击。也许在事情发生后，试着回到你以前的水平，或者回到基准线。
But this was something different. This is the idea that, oh, this terrible thing has happened. But somehow, we're gonna overcome it and we're gonna get to a place that's somehow better than before. And I'm wondering if you can almost summarize this way of thinking in a single line that you see all over social media nowadays, what doesn't kill you makes you stronger. Exactly.
但这有些不同。这是一种这样的观点：哦，这件可怕的事情发生了。但不知何故，我们要克服它，我们要达到一个比以前更好的境界。我想知道，你是否可以用你在当今社交网络上随处可见的一句话来概括这种思维方式：杀不死你的，使你更强大。正是如此。
And this happened, I think, in the last 10 or 15 years or so, right? This quote, which comes from Friedrich Nietzsche, the German philosopher. It's become almost like a culture of touch, Tony. And I remember, I think in the last three years, there have been songs by Kanye West and Klee Kloksen. What doesn't kill you makes you stronger? And I'm in power. That that don't kill me can only make me stronger. There have been memes that go around the internet. So it's almost like a default attitude towards trauma.
我认为这发生在过去10到15年左右，对吧？这句话出自德国哲学家弗里德里希·尼采。它几乎成了一种流行文化图腾。我记得，在过去的三年里，坎耶·韦斯特和凯莉·克拉克森都出过歌。杀不死你的会使你更强大？我在掌控之中。那些杀不死我的只会让我变得更强大。互联网上流传着各种表情包。所以这几乎成了对待创伤的一种默认态度。
Like when bad things happen, we're going to use this as an opportunity to become better. And that, to me, seems quintessentially American, the idea that we are going to take even the worst opportunities, the worst experiences, and make something positive out of them. Once Miranda noticed this phenomenon, he started remembering all the times he'd encountered it earlier in his life, particularly in American superhero movies. So when I was growing up in Sri Lanka when I was a small boy, I remember watching the original Superman movie with Christopher Reeve and Marlon Brando and the movie
就像当坏事发生时，我们要把它当作变得更好的机会。对我来说，这似乎具有典型的美国特色：我们要抓住最糟糕的机会、最糟糕的经历，从中创造出积极的东西。一旦伊兰达注意到这个现象，他就开始想起自己早年在生活中遇到过这种现象的所有时刻，特别是在美国超级英雄电影中。所以，当我还是斯里兰卡的一个小男孩时，我记得看过克里斯托弗·里夫和马龙·白兰度的原版超人电影，电影
begins with Superman as an infant leaving the planet Krypton before it's destroyed, trying to earth growing up on earth realizing he has superpowers and then becoming a superhero. And you know when I was young I just thought oh this is a you know a cool superhero story. And then once I moved to the US, I realized, well, it's interesting that so many superhero stories, the Batman movies, for example, or Spider-Man, right? So this is, it's a tend to follow a very similar plot. So the protagonist goes through some type of trauma, adverse event, and somehow that event is a catalyst. And I think buried in that narrative, right? It's this idea that bad things, right? In some cases, can lead to this growth
以超人作为婴儿离开即将毁灭的氪星开始，他来到地球，在地球上长大，意识到自己拥有超能力，然后成为了一名超级英雄。你知道，当我年轻的时候，我只是想，哦，这是一个很酷的超级英雄故事。然后，当我搬到美国后，我意识到，许多超级英雄故事——例如蝙蝠侠电影，或者蜘蛛侠——都很有趣，对吧？所以，它们往往遵循非常相似的情节。主角经历某种创伤、逆境事件，不知何故，该事件成为了催化剂。我认为，隐藏在这个叙事中的是这样一种观点：坏事情，对吧？在某些情况下，可以导致这种成长
or the development of specific abilities that makes you better off than before and also better off than most other people. And what I find fascinating, of course, is that this way of thinking about suffering is not new in America. In the 1950s, books and sermons by the clergyman Norman Vincent Peel became enormously influential.
或者特定能力的培养，使你的状况比以前更好，也比大多数其他人更好。当然，我发现迷人的是，这种看待苦难的方式在美国并不新鲜。在20世纪50年代，牧师诺曼·文森特·皮尔的书籍和布道产生了巨大的影响力。
The world is full of problems. For what reason? Why do we have so many problems? Why do you have so many problems? There's one answer to that. It is that you will grow strong, so that you're more and more capable of handling problems. The only way to make a strong man is through resistance. Struggle, pain, frustration, disappointment.
世界充满问题。为了什么原因？为什么我们有这么多问题？为什么你有这么多问题？答案只有一个。那就是你要变得强大，以便你越来越有能力处理问题。造就一个坚强的人的唯一途径就是通过阻力。奋斗、痛苦、挫折、失望。
This makes man. When I listen to that clip from Norman Vincent Peel, he's not just saying that suffering produces growth. He's actually saying, suffering exists in your life in order to produce growth. Right, and that's a very interesting claim, right? This idea that to some extent, in order for you to become the best person, you can be, in order for you to become the best person you can be, in order for you
这造就了人。当我听到诺曼·文森特·皮尔的这段音频时，他不仅是在说苦难催生成长。他实际上是在说，苦难存在于你的生活中，就是为了催生成长。没错，这是一个非常有趣的说法，对吧？这种观点认为，在某种程度上，为了让你成为最好的自己，为了让你成为最好的自己，为了让你
to sort of grow and character, suffering is necessary, right? And it makes it wonder whether that has something to do with the history of the United States, especially for people who had the freedom to immigrate to the United States, right? I mean, I think when they came to the US, there was this belief that the US is this land of plenty, there's all this opportunity, is up to you to make the most of it. And to the extent to which you're not able to make the most of it, it's because of something that you're not doing. And I wonder whether that culture, belief, is consistent with this view that pain and
在性格上成长，苦难是必要的，对吧？这让人不禁联想到，这是否与美国的历史有关，特别是对于那些有自由移民到美国的人来说，对吧？我的意思是，我认为当他们来到美国时，有一种信念，即美国是一片富饶的土地，这里有各种机遇，如何充分利用它们取决于你自己。如果你无法充分利用它们，那是因为你自身没有做好某些事。我想知道这种文化信念是否与痛苦和苦难是成长和改变的机遇这种观点相一致。
suffering are opportunities for growth for change. Now, this way of thinking about trauma and suffering is arguably no longer purely American. I feel like I've heard this theme now in many other contexts, perhaps because American culture increasingly permeates the whole world. But there are videos on TikTok and WhatsApp that talk about how, you know, like Generation 1 confronted suffering, built its character and pulled itself up by the bootstraps, Generation Two built on that hard work to create, you know, great companies or acquire political power, and then Generation Three squanders at all because those kids grew up in luxury and were not tested by adversity. Do you think it's possible that, to some extent, some of this American attitude has now started
现在，这种看待创伤和苦难的方式可以说不再仅仅属于美国。我觉得我现在在许多其他语境中也听过这个主题，也许是因为美国文化越来越多地渗透到全世界。但在TikTok和WhatsApp上有一些视频讨论，你知道的，比如第一代人面对苦难、磨练性格、白手起家；第二代人在这种艰苦工作的基础上创造了伟大的公司或获得了政治权力；然后第三代人挥霍一空，因为这些孩子在奢侈环境中长大，没有经历过逆境的考验。你认为有没有可能，在某种程度上，这种美国式的态度现在也开始
to rub off on the rest of the world as well, the sense that, you know, suffering exists in some ways to allow you to become a better version of yourself. I think there's something to that. You know, a couple of weeks ago in my graduate personality seminar, I was talking with my students about this narrative that adversity and trauma can lead to positive outcomes. And one of my students who is originally from China said, well, I do think this narrative is there in other countries as well, including in my country. What's interesting and different though is that in China, the idea is that adversity and suffering can lead to
潜移默化地影响了世界其他地方，让人觉得苦难在某种程度上存在是为了让你成为更好的自己？我觉得确实有这方面的因素。你知道，几周前在我的研究生人格研讨会上，我和学生们讨论了逆境和创伤可以带来积极结果这种叙事。我的一位原籍中国的学生说，嗯，我认为这种叙事在其他国家也存在，包括我的国家。不过有趣且不同的是，在中国，人们认为逆境和创伤可以带来
positive change at the national level, right, so that the country and the community can benefit. And he said there's a clear difference from maybe how Americans would think about the value of adversity and suffering because they were seen in terms of its value to the individual, or the its value to personal transformation. Very interesting. Now, you notice this theme of triumph over trauma turning up in the lives of the people you were getting to know in the United States, tell me about Meredith Russo, who she was, and how you became acquainted around her.
国家层面的积极变化，对吧，从而让国家和集体受益。他说，这与美国人看待逆境和苦难价值的方式有明显的不同，因为美国人是从它们对个人的价值，或者它们对个人转变的价值来看待的。非常有趣。现在，你注意到这种战胜创伤的主题出现在你在美国结识的人的生活中，跟我讲讲梅雷迪思·鲁索，她是谁，你是怎么和她结识的？
So Meredith Russo, she was a retired English instructor. She was very kind to me. I, how set for her multiple times, she would allow me to use her house to throw dinner parties for my friends, and she was just a very kind, generous, welcoming presence while I was in college as an international student. So I remember when she told me about her illness, and I went to visit her almost immediately. And she simply said, well, you know, I have cancer, the prognosis isn't good, but, you know, good take it day by day. And then she went on to talk about how part of what she was experiencing after her diagnosis
梅雷迪思·鲁索是一位退休的英语讲师。她对我很友好。我曾多次为她看家，她允许我借她的房子为我的朋友们举办晚宴，在我作为国际学生在大学期间，她一直是一个非常善良、慷慨、热情的人。所以当她告诉我她生病了的时候，我记得我几乎立刻就去看望她了。她只是说，嗯，你知道，我得了癌症，预后不太好，但，你知道，过一天算一天。然后她接着谈到，在她确诊后，她所经历的一部分事情是
where people talked about how she was gonna fight the cancer like a warrior that she was gonna defeat it. That was, it was really important to sort of, you know, take the right attitude about fighting cancer. You know, she thought, well, it seems like a lot of stress to think about cancer is something to be whankish. You know, I have it. I'm gonna manage with the best I can.
人们谈论她将如何像一个战士一样与癌症抗争，她将如何战胜它。这真的很重要，要对与癌症抗争抱有正确的态度。你知道，她想，把癌症当作某种需要你去猛烈抨击的东西，似乎会带来太大的压力。你知道，我得了病。我会尽我所能去应对它。
I probably don't have a lot of time left, but I'm gonna focus on what's important. And it seemed like this idea of being sort of a warrior about sort of somehow overcoming and like maybe even growing from sort of defeating cancer, it's truckers almost, I'm trying to find the right word here. It's truckers almost unnecessary. And she didn't like the fact that people
我可能没有太多时间了，但我会专注于重要的事情。而且似乎这种当战士、某种程度上战胜甚至可能通过战胜癌症而成长起来的想法，几乎让我感到……我在这里努力寻找合适的词。这几乎让人觉得没有必要。她不喜欢人们
were sort of encouraging her to take this more, almost warrior-like position towards the illness. Yeah, so people are telling her, you know, you're going to come out stronger than before, or there's a reason this is happening. And for the person who's actually suffering from the cancer, it now feels like they not only have to deal with the cancer, but they have to deal now with the expectations that they've been bequeathed a gift to actually become some kind of superior person, some kind of superhero.
某种程度上鼓励她对疾病采取这种几乎像战士一样的立场。是的，所以人们告诉她，你知道的，你会比以前更强大地走出来，或者这件事发生是有原因的。而对于真正遭受癌症折磨的人来说，现在感觉他们不仅要应付癌症，还要应付这样一种期望：他们被赋予了一份天赋，要去成为某种超人般的存在、某种超级英雄。
Exactly. And I think it's especially strange to be given that type of advice, right? That this is a gift, this is opportunity. When you are still sort of thinking about the emotional response that you have and you're given the news, right? That it seems very quick to move from, oh, you have this like, a very serious situation to, oh, but this is the opportunity that you can learn from. Oh, this is an opportunity where you can sort of grow your character, become the best possible version of yourself.
完全正确。而且我认为被给予这种类型的建议是极其奇怪的，对吧？即这是一份礼物，这是一个机会。当你还在思考你听到这个消息时的情感反应时，对吧？从“哦，你遇到了这样一个非常严重的情况”迅速转变为“哦，但这是一个你可以从中学习的机会。哦，这是一个你可以借此磨练性格、成为最好的自己的机会”。
So by this point you were starting to become a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania, you were in grad school, and you discovered that the triumphant over adversity trope or the superhero trope was not only dominant in American popular culture, but it was a booming area in psychological research. Can you tell me about the idea of post-traumatic growth? What does that mean and how that connected with this larger cultural trope? Post-traumatic growth refers to this idea that people can experience positive psychological
所以到了这个时候，你开始成为宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家，你在读研究生，你发现战胜逆境的主题或超级英雄主题不仅在美国流行文化中占据主导地位，而且在心理学研究中也是一个蓬勃发展的领域。你能跟我讲讲创伤后成长这个概念吗？这是什么意思，它又是如何与这个更大的文化主题联系在一起的？创伤后成长指的是这样一种观点：人们可以经历积极的心理
changes as a result of going through stressful life experiences. Research and post-traumatic growth, you know, sort of started taking off in the mid-1990s. A lot of the early research and post-traumatic growth, I think, was based on interviews that clinicians were doing with clients who had gone through trauma, gone through adversity, and they were trying to categorize the types of benefits these clients would report in their clinical interviews and in the last 20 years you know work and research and interest in post-traumatic growth has exploded.
改变，作为经历压力生活事件的结果。对创伤后研究和创伤后成长的研究，你知道，大约在20世纪90年代中期开始腾飞。我认为，早期关于创伤后成长的很多研究，是基于临床医生对经历过创伤、经历过逆境的客户进行的访谈，他们试图对这些客户在临床访谈中报告的益处类型进行分类。而在过去的20年里，你知道，关于创伤后成长的工作、研究和兴趣已经呈爆炸式增长。
I can tell you that in the last six months I think I've seen at least three papers looking at post-traumatic growth in the wake of COVID and I'm sure there are quite a few more that are in the pipeline. Even as some clinicians were telling patients that traumatic events could lead to growth, other researchers said, hang on. Are people reporting growth because they've grown? Or are they saying so because the superhero trope
我可以告诉你，在过去六个月里，我想我至少看到了三篇关于新冠肺炎疫情后创伤后成长的论文，而且我敢肯定还有相当多的论文正在筹备中。甚至在一些临床医生告诉患者创伤事件可以带来成长时，其他研究人员却说，等一下。人们报告成长是因为他们真的成长了吗？还是他们这么说，只是因为超级英雄主题
is so dominant in the culture? Irranda cites a paper by the research of Patricia Frazier. So I was a graduate student when I started becoming interested in looking at post-traumatic growth and I remember reading this paper when it came out and it was a very elegant, simple paper. It was a short-term, longitudinal study. It was a study that tracked a large number of undergraduate students over a few months.
在文化中如此占主导地位？伊兰达引用了研究员帕特里夏·弗雷泽的一篇论文。所以当我开始对研究创伤后成长产生兴趣时，我是一名研究生，我记得这篇论文发表时我读了它，这是一篇非常优雅、简单的论文。这是一项短期纵向研究。它是一项在几个月内追踪大量本科生的研究。
And it asked them whether they experienced a major stressful event. And then they were asked, okay, as a result of the stress for a event, how much have you changed because of the trauma? So it turns out that this question, how much you think you've changed because of the trauma, is the way most measures of post-traumatic growth asks about change. And this paper made me realize that even though most theories about post-traumatic growth were talking about post-traumatic growth in terms of personality transformation, the measures of post-traumatic growth were actually looking at something different,
它询问他们是否经历了重大的压力事件。然后他们被问到，好吧，由于这个压力事件，因为创伤你改变了多少？事实上，这个问题——你认为因为创伤你改变了多少——就是大多数创伤后成长衡量标准询问变化的方式。这篇论文让我意识到，尽管大多数关于创伤后成长的理论都是从人格转变的角度来讨论创伤后成长的，但创伤后成长的衡量标准实际上在观察不同的东西，
which was the perception of change. And what they found was that while people who had experienced real change had better quality mental health, the people who reported perceiving high levels of change as a result of experiencing the trauma or the adverse event, actually reported higher levels of mental distress. So from the point of view of someone who was now just looking at this larger, you know, American cultural trope, what I'm what I'm going to now call the superhero trope, that, you know, bad, bad things produce extraordinary qualities to come out inside you, is it fair to say that this study in some ways was pointing to the fact that if you subscribe very strongly to this belief, the superhero trope belief, but
那就是对变化的感知。他们发现，虽然真正经历过改变的人拥有更好的心理健康质量，但那些因为经历创伤或逆境而报告感知到高度改变的人，实际上报告了更高水平的心理痛苦。所以，从一个刚刚在审视这个更大的、你知道的，美国文化主题——我现在要称之为超级英雄主题——的人的角度来看，即坏事会激发出你内在的非凡品质，公平地说，这项研究在某种程度上是否在表明：如果你非常强烈地认同这种信念，即超级英雄主题信念，但
didn't actually have the changes in your life, not only was this not good, but it could actually be bad. I think that's right. What was happening was that people were having these beliefs about benefits or growth that experience as a way to cope with the traumatic event that gone through. So in some ways, having these beliefs was potentially serving the role of making them think about their event in a more manageable way, maybe make them establish a greater sense of control over the event.
你的生活并没有真正发生改变，这不仅无益，甚至可能有害？我认为确实如此。发生的情况是，人们对经历带来的益处或成长抱有这些信念，以此作为应对他们所经历的创伤事件的一种方式。因此在某种程度上，抱有这些信念可能起到了这样的作用：让他们以一种更容易掌控的方式看待事件，也许让他们对事件建立起一种更强烈的掌控感。
And I think one lesson from the Frasier paper is that this coping strategy of perceiving growth didn't seem like a particularly effective one, at least for the sample. Now, there was another study this one conducted with soldiers deployed to Iraq. Can you tell me what that paper found around it? Yes, this is a paper that looked at soldiers from the Netherlands that were deployed to Iraq. And what was nice about this paper is that it tracked people, I think, across 15 months.
我认为弗雷泽论文给我们的一个教训是，这种感知成长的应对策略似乎并不是一个特别有效的策略，至少对这个样本而言是这样。现在，还有另一项研究，这项研究是对部署到伊拉克的士兵进行的。你能告诉我那篇论文发现了什么吗？是的，这是一篇研究被部署到伊拉克的荷兰士兵的论文。这篇论文的好处在于它追踪了人们，我想，大约15个月的时间。
And this paper explicitly looked at the question of whether perceiving growth served as an adaptive coping strategy. And what they found was that perceived growth actually predicted increased impairment in terms of PTSD symptoms. In other words, the soldiers who perceived that they had grown as a result of adversity were actually more likely than other soldiers to experience symptoms of PTSD. The belief was supposed to be helping, but it led to worse outcomes.
这篇论文明确探讨了“感知成长是否作为一种适应性应对策略”的问题。他们发现，感知到的成长实际上预示着创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）症状的加剧。换句话说，那些认为自己因为逆境而成长了的士兵，实际上比其他士兵更有可能经历创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的症状。这种本该提供帮助的信念，却导致了更糟糕的结果。
Yet, the idea that people who experienced trauma would benefit from their trauma proved irresistible. Increasingly, this trope has been actively recommended to patients as a path to recovery. Around 10 or 15 years ago, there was a lot of interest in trying to promote these beliefs about post-traumatic growth among cancer patients because there was this belief that maybe growth could help them improve the quality of life. And this led to this pretty acrimony as the bit where you had researchers advocating for post-traumatic growth, talking about the potential benefits of growth, the fact that large proportions
然而，“经历创伤的人将从创伤中受益”这一想法被证明是不可抗拒的。这种主题越来越多地被积极推荐给患者，作为通往康复的途径。大约10到15年前，人们对试图在癌症患者中推广关于创伤后成长的这些信念产生了极大的兴趣，因为当时有一种信念认为，也许成长可以帮助他们改善生活质量。这导致了相当激烈的争论，一方面是倡导创伤后成长的研究人员，谈论成长的潜在好处、很大比例的
of people report high levels of growth, and then you had detractors saying we haven't properly distinguished between perceived growth and post-traumatic growth. And the existing evidence suggests that growth understood as perceived change doesn't have a meaningful impact on the quality of life or the longevity of cancer patients. And this speaks to one of the challenges of doing this type of research in the context of a culture that really validates this superhero trope, right, or this idea that, you know, adversity can lead to this positive outcomes. I think it's easier for people to accept research that speaks to their own pre-existing beliefs. And I think what happened with post-traumatic growth research was that people were willing
人报告高水平成长的现象；而另一方面是批评者，他们说我们没有恰当地区分“感知成长”和“创伤后成长”。现有的证据表明，被理解为感知到的改变的成长，对癌症患者的生活质量或寿命并没有产生有意义的影响。这也道出了在真正认可这个超级英雄主题——或者“逆境可以带来积极结果”这种观点——的文化背景下进行此类研究所面临的挑战之一，对吧？我认为人们更容易接受符合他们自身既有信念的研究。我认为创伤后成长研究所发生的事情是，人们愿意
to jump ahead and make strong claims about the evidence before the right kind of evidence could be procured. right kind of evidence could be procured. Iran does not have to wonder, does the post-traumatic growth narrative give people hope and inspiration, or does it demand that people suffering trauma not only survive it, but show evidence they have come out stronger on the other side? When we come back, Iran does contrast what he was seeing in the United States with his own experience of dealing with conflict in Sri Lanka. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. American culture insists that hard times can
在能够获得正确类型的证据之前，就急于得出结论并对证据做出强有力的断言。在能够获得正确类型的证据之前，就急于得出结论并对证据做出强有力的断言。伊兰达不得不思考，创伤后成长的叙事是给了人们希望和启示，还是要求遭受创伤的人不仅要挺过去，还要拿出证据证明他们在另一边变得更强大了？广告回来后，伊兰达将他在美国看到的情景与他在斯里兰卡应对冲突的亲身经历进行了对比。您收听的是《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。美国文化坚信，艰难困苦可以
make us into better, more successful people. What doesn't kill us makes us stronger. After moving to the United States to study psychology, Iranda Jayawikrama began to ask if this popular trope was doing more harm than good. He had a reference point, his own experience growing up in Sri Lanka. Through much of the 1980s and 90s, the minority Tamil population of Sri Lanka and the Sinali's majority were locked in a brutal civil war. Tens of thousands of people were killed.
把我们变成更好、更成功的人。杀不死我们的，使我们更强大。在移居美国学习心理学后，伊兰达·贾亚维克拉马开始思考这个流行的主题是否弊大于利。他有一个参照点，那就是自己在斯里兰卡长大的经历。在整个20世纪80和90年代，斯里兰卡的泰米尔少数族裔与僧伽罗多数族裔陷入了一场残酷的内战。数万人丧生。
The conflict featured terrible acts of cruelty on all sides. Iranda, you were a kid in Sri Lanka when the civil war unfolded. How much were you allowed to see as a child? My everyday experience as a 9-10-year-old going around Colombo, which is where we lived, was seen, right, the bodies of people who had been, you know, abducted, tortured, killed, and left on the side of the street. And looking back on that, I wanted them struck by just the extent to which I thought that was normal. I had no comparison. I just thought, oh, we don't get to go to school. All this stuff is happening around us.
冲突各方都上演了惨绝人寰的残酷行径。伊兰达，内战爆发时你还是斯里兰卡的一个孩子。作为孩子，你被允许看到多少？作为9到10岁的孩子，我在我们居住的科伦坡四处走动的日常经历是，看到的，对吧，是那些被，你知道的，绑架、折磨、杀害并遗弃在街头的尸体。回想起来，我被我当时认为这很正常的程度所震撼。我没有参照物。我只是想，哦，我们不用去学校了。所有这些事情都在我们周围发生。
But I just didn't think too much about it. And I think that set the stage for a pretty high degree of normalization or extreme violence. And I think for many people who grew up in Sri Lanka in the 80s and 90s that was very much the norm and even though, you know, I grew up in a relatively affluent middle-class household so we were spared many of the, you know, the terrible atrocities that were committed both in the insurrection and in the civil war but this, you know, this attitude of a bomb might go up in you under bus you have to be careful if you see someone suspicious. You know these types of behaviors and these types of beliefs just became normalized. I remember so we moved to candy when we were I think 14 years old and in 1998 I think when the
但我只是没有过多地思考它。我认为这为极高程度的极端暴力正常化奠定了基础。而且我认为对于许多在80和90年代在斯里兰卡长大的人来说，这非常符合常态，尽管，你知道的，我在一个相对富裕的中产阶级家庭长大，所以我们免于遭受许多，你知道的，无论是在暴动还是内战中犯下的可怕暴行，但是，这种，你知道的，炸弹可能会在你的公交车上爆炸，如果你看到可疑人员必须小心的态度。你知道，这些类型的行为和这些类型的信念变得正常化了。我记得，所以当我们大约14岁时，我们搬到了康提，1998年，我想是
Timotakers blew up the temple of the tooth, this major Buddhist shrine in candy. So we were a couple of miles away from the blast. I remember how shook when the moment of the moment of the Oh, something's happened. And I think it was interesting that I felt comfortable traveling out to the city centre that afternoon to see my friends and to see what was happening. I remember visiting my friend who lived close to the temple and all the windows in his house had been blown through. But it felt weirdly mundane because they'd degree to which we had become sort of accustomed to the type of
泰米尔猛虎组织炸毁了康提的佛牙寺，这是那里的一个主要佛教圣地。所以我们距离爆炸发生地只有几英里远。我记得当爆炸发生那一刻……哦，有什么事情发生了。而且我觉得很有趣的是，那天下午我仍然很放心地去市中心看望我的朋友，看看发生了什么。我记得去拜访住在寺庙附近的朋友，他家所有的窗户都被震碎了。但感觉诡异地平常，因为我们已经习惯了
violence that we saw going on in Sri Lanka at that time. I mean, it's astonishing that your parents simply let you out of the house. I mean, you know, there was a bomb blast that went off two miles away and a few hours later you're traipsing out to a friend's house. I mean, that's kind of astonishing. I think looking back it might be that we made a decision that, well, the bombs already happened. Chances are something is not going to happen again.
当时在斯里兰卡发生的暴力活动。我的意思是，你的父母居然直接让你出门，这太令人震惊了。我的意思是，你知道的，两英里外发生了炸弹爆炸，几个小时后你却溜达到朋友家去。我的意思是，这有点令人震惊。我想回过头来看，可能是我们做出了一种决定，那就是，炸弹已经炸过了。再次发生事情的几率不大了。
So we felt comfortable going out. And I will also say, and it was true that there was a degree of difference between what people in candy and columball were experiencing and what people in the North and East of the country are experiencing, right? People who are actually caught up in the civil war, right? So there's this, I think there's a sense in which maybe implicitly, explicitly, we believe that compared to other people, this wasn't too bad, right? But these we weren't living in a war zone.
所以我们觉得出门很舒服。而且我还要说，康提和科伦坡的人们所经历的，与国家北部和东部的人们所经历的之间，确实存在一定程度的差异，对吧？那些真正卷入内战的人，对吧？所以，我认为某种程度上，可能含蓄地，也可能明确地，我们相信，与其他地方的人相比，这不算太糟，对吧？我们并没有生活在战区。
We talked earlier about how you move to the United States shortly before the 9-11 attacks. When the attacks happen, you'll notice something about your own reaction We talked earlier about how you moved to the United States shortly before the 9-11 attacks. When the attacks happened, you noticed something about your own reaction to the attacks. What did you notice around that? I remember this very vividly. I was in class that morning when they announced that the first plane had hit the World Trade Center. I think because of that point, people thought it was still an accident.
我们之前讨论过你是如何在9·11袭击发生前不久搬到美国的。袭击发生时，你注意到了自己的一些反应……我们之前讨论过你是如何在9·11袭击发生前不久搬到美国的。袭击发生时，你注意到了自己对袭击的一些反应。伊兰达，你注意到了什么？我对此记忆犹新。那天早上我正在上课，广播里宣布第一架飞机撞上了世界贸易中心。我想因为当时人们以为这还是一起事故。
We continued with class. And then it was after my first class of the day that it became clear that this was actually a cornered attack. People in shock and they canceled classes the rest of the day. They set up TV sets and they gave out food. And my first thought was, well, this is bad. But it also weirdly feels like home. And my thought was, oh, this is bad, but I don't think it struck me just how bad it would have felt to other people around me. And it was only later that evening, there was an interfaith memorial service that I went for. And there were professors who were there, and they were crying, they were sobbing, because there were seniors who had graduated that spring, who had gone to work on Wall Street, who had gone to work at the World Trade Center. And they didn't know where they were. They tried to contact them, right?
我们继续上课。然后在当天的第一节课后，情况变得清楚起来，这实际上是一起有预谋的袭击。人们处于震惊之中，学校取消了当天剩下的课程。他们架起电视机，分发食物。我的第一反应是，嗯，这很糟糕。但它也诡异地让我感到像是在家。我的想法是，哦，这很糟糕，但我认为它没有让我意识到这对周围的其他其他人来说有多糟糕。直到那天傍晚晚些时候，我参加了一个跨宗教追悼会。那里有教授们，他们在哭泣，在啜泣，因为今年春天刚刚毕业的大四学生，去华尔街工作了，去世界贸易中心工作了。而他们不知道这些人在哪里。他们试图联系他们，对吧？
They were beside themselves with grief. And I remember thinking at that moment, something's wrong here. Like I seem to, I feel like I'm having a response to this attack that doesn't seem right. I mean, you were almost responding with a sense of detachment to this terrible thing that was happening around you.
他们悲痛欲绝。我记得当时我在想，这里有些不对劲。我似乎，我觉得我对这次袭击的反应似乎不太对劲。我的意思是，面对周围发生的可怖事情，你几乎是用一种抽离的感觉在做出反应。
Exactly. And it also speaks to the fact that time is that, you know, what seemed relatively normal to me as someone who grew up in Sri Lanka was something that I was realizing was not normal to many other people, at least for people who lived in, you know, in this part of the world. After he became a psychologist, Iranda started to ask himself whether his own response to the trauma of the Sri Lankan civil war revealed in our growth. When he looked at himself honestly, he didn't see growth.
完全正确。这也说明了这样一个事实：作为在斯里兰卡长大的人，对我来说显得相对正常的事情，我意识到对许多其他人来说并不正常，至少对那些生活在，你知道的，世界这个部分的人来说是这样。成为心理学家后，伊兰达开始问自己，他自己对斯里兰卡内战创伤的反应是否暴露出成长。当他诚实地审视自己时，他没有看到成长。
He saw heartening, desensitization, even indifference. Now you could argue if you like Norman Vincent Peel, that hardness is growth. But was apathy in the face of suffering really a sign that trauma had made him a better person? When Iran then returned to Sri Lanka to do research on post-traumatic growth, he interviewed other people who had been traumatized by the civil war. He saw lots of people who were like himself or worse. It makes no sense to talk to them about what happened to you last week or what was a terrible thing that's impacted your life, right? Because these are people of undergone multiple traumas
他看到了冷酷、脱敏，甚至是漠不关己。现在，如果你喜欢诺曼·文森特·皮尔，你可能会辩称这种冷酷就是成长。但面对苦难时的冷漠真的是创伤让他成为更好的人的标志吗？当伊兰达后来回到斯里兰卡开展关于创伤后成长的研究时，他采访了其他受内战创伤的人。他看到许多人和他自己一样，甚至更糟。跟他们谈论你上周发生了什么或对你生活产生了可怕影响的事情是没有意义的，对吧？因为这些人经历过多重创伤
of all types. And you know, one thing that struck home for me in those interviews is that unlike in the United States, you know, most shiranigans home for me in those interviews is that, unlike in the United States, most shiran kan's don't want to talk at length about their experiences, about their trauma. There's no sort of investigation into what this means for who am I as a person, or what I can grow from it, or change from it, or what lessen it can take from it, all the conversations that I had with people are very matter of fact. If I pushed them on the experiences I had, they would just sort of list them
各种各样的创伤。你知道，在那些访谈中让我刻骨铭心的一点是，与美国不同，你知道，大多数斯里兰卡人回到那些访谈中时，与美国不同，大多数斯里兰卡人并不想长篇大论地谈论他们的经历，他们的创伤。没有对“这对我是什么样的人意味着什么”进行任何形式的探究，也没有探讨我能从中获得什么成长、改变，或者能从中吸取什么教训——我和人们的所有谈话都非常对事不对人。如果我追问他们的经历，他们只会把它们列举出来
one after another and that would be it. You know, the extent to which it was clear that day-to-day function had been impacted by trauma varied. There were some people who did come across as very resilient and very positive despite the adversities that gone through, right? Not too many, maybe one or two. But there were many people who you could tell were just struggling to function day to day, right? There was one person who came to speak to us because that person was hoping that I could help her find her son. And that was like a heartbreaking discussion to have, right? You know, it was clear she was struggling,
一个接一个，然后就结束了。你知道，创伤对日常功能造成影响的程度各不相同。确实有些人尽管经历了逆境，依然表现得非常具有韧性和积极性，对吧？不多，也许一两个。但你可以看出许多人仅仅是在艰难维系日常生活，对吧？曾有一个人来找我们说话，因为那个人希望我能帮她找到她的儿子。那是一次令人心碎的交流，对吧？你知道的，很明显她在苦苦挣扎，
it was clear that she could barely function in daily life, but she came to the meeting because she was hoping that talking to me about her son would maybe open up a new possibility that he could be found. So you weren't satisfied with the approach that you were seeing in Sri Lanka, kind of avoidance that left people isolated in their pain, but you also weren't satisfied with the American approach. This polyanish optimism that told people that tragedy would make them better versions of themselves. So you started to examine if there was a third way and you began to look for answers, not just in science, but in philosophy and theology. Why did you do that around there and what did you find? My first thought was, okay, to the extent to which adversity can lead to change, in what
很明显她几乎无法维持日常生活，但她来开会是因为她希望跟我谈谈她的儿子也许能带来找到他的新可能。所以你对你在斯里兰卡看到的方法并不满意，那种让人们在痛苦中孤立无援的逃避；但你对美国的方法同样不满意。那种告诉人们悲剧会让他们成为更好版本的自己的盲目乐观。所以你开始研究是否存在第三条道路，你开始寻找答案，不仅在科学中，还在哲学和神学中。埃兰达，你为什么要这么做？你发现了什么？我的第一个想法是，好吧，在逆境能够导致改变的范围内，你期望在哪些
domains would you expect to see change? And in looking at the literature in philosophy, looking at different religious traditions, looking at theology, one idea ahead was that, well, it might be that to accentuate these different traditions, talk about suffering, how to deal with it, how to move past it, there might be valuable insights that could come from these different traditions. And in the last few years, there have been many people have argued that a fundamental role of religion
领域看到改变？通过查阅哲学文献、审视不同的宗教传统、研究神学，我发现的一个观点是，嗯，为了强调这些不同的传统如何谈论苦难、如何处理苦难、如何超越苦难，这些不同的传统可能会产生宝贵的见解。在过去的几年里，有许多人认为宗教的基本作用
isn't to tell you a story about creation or to tell you a story about why you should be a moral, a good person. The fundamental role of religion is to help us understand why they're suffering and trauma in the world. Why do the people that we love get sick and leave us at some point? Why do we suffer unavoidable pain, undeserved suffering? These are fundamental existential questions that we can't, you know, immediately answer rationally. So my thought was that
不是给你讲一个关于创世的故事，也不是告诉你为什么你应该成为一个有道德、善良的人。宗教的基本作用是帮助我们理解为什么世界上会有苦难和创伤。为什么我们所爱的人会生病并在某个时刻离开我们？为什么我们要遭受不可避免的痛苦、不该承受的苦难？这些是基本的生存问题，我们无法，你知道的，立即用理性去回答。所以我的想法是，
looking at different religions, looking at theology, looking at different philosophical traditions, I try to explain the role and value of suffering and adversity, these traditions might give us a better understanding of where we could see change. In the Buddhist tradition, there's this idea that it's important to understand that life is fundamentally about suffering. And once you accept that core truth about life, it opens up the possibility, right, for you to attain specific virtues, that compassion, that would enable you to lead a good life. Similarly, in the Christian tradition, one lesson that suffering can provide us is that we are vulnerable creatures that we need other people that were fundamentally interdependent and that insight is available listen that
通过审视不同的宗教、神学和不同的哲学传统，我试图解释苦难和逆境的作用与价值，这些传统可能会让我们更好地理解我们在哪里可以看到改变。在佛教传统中，有这样一种观点：重要的是要明白生命本质上就是充满苦难的。一旦你接受了关于生命的这一核心真理，它就会为你打开可能的大门，让你获得特定的美德，比如同情心，这将使你过上美好的生活。同样，在基督教传统中，苦难可以给我们带来的一课是，我们是脆弱的生物，我们需要其他人，我们本质上是相互依存的，这种洞察力是可以汲取的教训，
suffering can teach you. So you began your own research on the role of adversity in promoting this kind of character development and you became alert to an emerging body of research within psychology That was demonstrating the potential for suffering to lead to things like compassion or wisdom or creativity For example, you found the work of the psychologist David Distanio and Daniel Lim who had examined empirically how adversity affected people's capacity for compassion. Tell me what they found around them They assist adversity through a checklist where people were asked across your whole life,
苦难可以教导你。因此，你开始了自己的研究，探讨逆境在促进这种性格发展中的作用，并且你开始注意到心理学内部正在兴起的一批研究，这些研究展示了苦难带来同情心、智慧或创造力等特质的潜力。例如，你发现了心理学家大卫·德斯蒂诺和丹尼尔·林的工作，他们通过实证检验了逆境如何影响人们的同情心能力。埃兰达，请告诉我他们发现了什么。他们通过一份清单来评估逆境，清单上人们被问到，在你的整个人生中，
tell us what major stressful life events we experienced. And what they found was that if you look to the relationship between the number of adverse life events people reported in their lifetime and the expression of compassion. They found that people who were experienced high levels of community life and adversity were more compassionate. They were more willing to engage in pro-social behavior. They also found that to accentuate, should experience high levels of community life and adversity, you were less prone to be overwhelmed by the number of people who are suffering, right?
告诉我们你经历了哪些重大的压力生活事件。他们发现，如果你审视人们一生中报告的逆境生活事件数量与同情心表达之间的关系。他们发现，经历过高度社区生活和逆境的人更有同情心。他们更愿意参与亲社会行为。他们还发现，强调经历过高度社区生活和逆境的人，不那么容易被受苦受难的人数所压倒，对吧？
So this is called the numeracy bias. So the idea is that when you see one person suffering, you feel like, oh, I can do something with that person. But when you hear that like a whole country has a refugee crisis, you tend not to get involved because you feel like, well, this is overwhelming. I don't think I can do anything about this. So I'm not going to engage. It turns out that people who have experienced a high level of lifetime adversity are immune to this bias.
所以这被称为数字偏差。这种想法是，当你看到一个人在受苦时，你会觉得，哦，我可以为那个人做点什么。但当你听说整个国家遭遇难民危机时，你往往不会参与其中，因为你觉得，嗯，这太 overwhelming 了。我不认为我能对此做些什么。所以我不打算参与。事实证明，经历过高水平终身逆境的人对这种偏差具有免疫力。
So one implication from these studies is that they something about experiencing different types of adverse events that seems to increase your empathy towards other people, that seems to make you most sensitive to the needs of others. In other words, suffering and trauma don't always produce growth. When they do, that growth is unlikely to follow the arc of your standard superhero movie. Instead of getting tougher, growth may take the form of increased compassion and empathy. There are caveats however. Trauma can also decrease empathy and compassion. Remember how Iran responded to the 9-11 attacks. It turns out trauma alone usually does not
因此，这些研究的一个启示是，经历不同类型的逆境事件似乎能以某种方式增强你对其他人的同理心，似乎能让你对其他人的需求最敏感。换句话说，苦难和创伤并不总能带来成长。当它们确实带来成长时，这种成长也不太可能遵循你标准的超级英雄电影的剧情。成长可能不会变得更坚强，而是表现为同情心和同理心的增强。然而，这里也有注意事项。创伤也会减少同理心和同情心。还记得伊朗对 9-11 袭击的反应吗？事实证明，单靠创伤通常并不能
produce wisdom and compassion. A lot comes down to how you process trauma, how you reflect on your own suffering. One study along these lines was conducted by the psychologists Judith Gluck and Nick Westreight. Yes, so you've been doing research on wisdom for many years now. Nick Westreight, a later project with her, looking at what predicts whether someone experiences changes and well-being in the wake of adverse life events.
产生智慧和同情心。很大程度上取决于你如何处理创伤，如何反思自己的痛苦。沿着这些思路进行的一项研究是由心理学家朱迪思·格拉克（Judith Gluck）和尼克·韦斯特赖特（Nick Westreight）进行的。是的，所以你多年来一直在研究智慧。尼克·韦斯特赖特，她后来的一个项目，研究是什么预测了某人在经历逆境生活事件后是否会经历幸福感的改变。
And they found that how you thought about the event was a critical factor in determining whether you subsequently experienced changes in wisdom and changes in well-being. Specifically, Nick and you that looked at this construct called exploratory processing, are the extent to which you sort of reflect on the event, right, you try and think, okay, what does this event mean to me?
他们发现，你如何看待这一事件是决定你随后是否经历智慧改变和幸福感改变的关键因素。具体来说，尼克和你研究了一种叫做探索性加工的概念，即你在多大程度上对事件进行某种反思，对吧，你试着思考，好吧，这个事件对意味着什么？
How do I make sense of this? How can I use this event as an opportunity for me to do something different with my life? And in a study that they ran a few years ago, they found that to the extent to which people engage in that type of self-reflection. Those people are much more likely to increase in wisdom and increase in well-being after going through a change in life event. Setbacks in adversity do not magically produce growth and build character. Trauma is just as likely to cause us to turn away from others and become embittered.
我该如何理解这一点？我如何能利用这个事件作为契机，让我的生活做出一些改变？在他们几年前进行的一项研究中，他们发现，人们进行这种自我反思的程度。这些人经历生活事件的改变后，智慧和幸福感增加的可能性要大得多。挫折和逆境并不能神奇地产生成长并塑造品格。创伤同样很有可能导致我们疏远他人并变得痛苦。
When we come back, how to cultivate character strengths, following setbacks and adversity. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Aranda Jaya Vikramma is a psychologist at Wake Forest University. He studies how we respond to hardships. He explores how suffering can provide a platform for cultivating character strengths like compassion, wisdom and resourcefulness.
当我们回来时，如何培养品格优势，在经历挫折和逆境之后。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。伊兰达·贾亚维克拉马（Iranda Jayawickrama）是维克森林大学的心理学家。他研究我们如何应对艰难困境。他探讨了苦难如何能为培养同情心、智慧和机智等品格优势提供一个平台。
Irranda, you've long been inspired by Victor Franco, the Holocaust survivor who wrote man's search for meaning. Can you tell our listeners what the book is about and how it's spoken to you? So yeah, I remember reading Victor Franco as a sophomore in college, and I remember even back then, being struck by the message of the book. The book is about the experience that Victor Franker had in a concentration camp during the Second World War. And specifically, it was about his experience how he was able to maintain a sense of control over his life, despite the complete lack of control he had from an objective standpoint. And one of the core lessons of that book is even when you have no control over your environment, you can still exert some degree of control
伊兰达，你长期以来一直受到维克多·弗兰克尔（Victor Frankl）的启发，这位幸存者写下了《人类寻找意义》（Man's Search for Meaning）。你能告诉我们的听众这本书讲的是什么，它又是如何触动你的吗？是的，我记得在大学二年级时读过维克多·弗兰克尔，我记得即使在那个时候，我也被这本书的信息深深打动了。这本书讲述了维克多·弗兰克尔在第二次世界大战期间在集中营的经历。具体来说，是关于他的经历，即尽管客观上完全缺乏控制，他是如何在生活中保持一种控制感的。这本书的核心教训之一是，即使你对环境没有任何控制，你仍然可以在某种程度上施加控制
over your reaction to the environment, especially in context where you feel like there's nothing you can do to make the situation better. Believe me that well, at least I can control my own reaction to the situation better. Believing that well at least I can control my own reaction to the situation, I think gives you some degree of agency, right? That allows you to both maintain an adequate level of well-being in the moment. And also, you know, maintain some degree of hope to think that well, things are terrible now, but at least they're supposed to be able to, it things to be better in the future.
对环境的反应，特别是在你觉得自己无能为力以改善现状的环境中。相信至少我可以更好地控制自己对这种情况的反应。相信至少我可以控制自己对这种情况的反应，我认为这会给你带来一定程度的主动性，对吧？这既能让你在当下保持适度的幸福感。同时，你知道，也保持某种程度的希望，认为情况现在很糟糕，但至少将来情况会变好。
So psychological research has begun to build on testimonies like this, this idea that we can choose our own responses to adversity. And this research makes a distinction between what's called primary control and secondary control. What are those two modes of control, Miranda? Primary control is what I think most people, at least most Americans, would think of as
因此，心理学研究开始建立在这样的证词之上，即我们可以选择自己对逆境的反应。这项研究区分了所谓的初级控制和次级控制。伊兰达，这两种控制模式是什么？初级控制是我认为大多数人，至少大多数美国人会认为是
a control. Our agency is when you use your own actions to modify or change the environment. Security control is when you can't change the environment. Or maybe for example, the health diagnosis, you just can't change objectively. In those cases, the focus of control is not on the environment, but on your own thoughts. So while primary control involves changing the environment, secondary control involves changing your own reaction to the environment.
控制。我们的主动性是指你用自己的行动去修改或改变环境。安全控制是指你无法改变环境。或者可能例如健康诊断，你就是客观上无法改变。在这些情况下，控制的焦点不在于环境，而在于你自己的思想。因此，虽然初级控制涉及改变环境，但次级控制涉及改变你对环境的反应。
There's been a lot of work that looks at the difference between these two approaches. In a study that you conducted with Eric Helzer, you assessed how much people exercise this control over the external world versus control over the internal world. And then you measured how satisfied they were with their lives. Can you describe the study for me and what you found around there?
有很多工作着眼于这两种方法之间的区别。在你与埃里克·赫尔泽（Eric Helzer）共同进行的一项研究中，你评估了人们对外部世界的这种控制与对内部世界的控制相比有多少。然后你测量了他们对生活的满意度。你能为我描述一下这项研究以及你在那里发现了什么吗？
We had this idea that primary security control worked together to promote well-being. In the literature, there's an assumption that primary control is what's most important, and that you fall back on security control when you don't have an option with the hope that in the future you can then revert back to primary control. Our perspective was that well, no, maybe we use these different control strategies as tools to deal with different types of challenges in our world. So we ran a study to look at the unique impact
我们有这样的想法：初级安全控制共同作用以促进幸福感。在文献中，有一种假设认为初级控制是最重要的，当你没有选择时，你会退回到安全控制，希望将来你能恢复到初级控制。我们的观点是，不，也许我们使用这些不同的控制策略作为工具来应对我们世界中不同类型的挑战。所以我们进行了一项研究来观察其独特的影响
each of these control strategies had on well-being. And we found that these two strategies independently predicted well-being, primary control or control over environment, tended to be associated with high levels of possible emotions, whereas secondary control had this relationship with life satisfaction. So they're both very tools that we can use to promote our
这些控制策略中的每一个都对幸福感有影响。我们发现这两种策略独立地预测了幸福感，初级控制或对环境的控制往往与高水平的可能情绪相关，而次级控制与生活满意度有这种关系。所以它们都是非常好的工具，我们可以用它们来促进我们的
wellbeing in daily life. So in other words, when it is absolutely the case that trying to limit the traumas that affect us, changing the external world, obviously that does help, that is, that does produce positive outcomes, it is also the case that changing our response to those traumatic events that independently can also promote our well-being. Exactly. And it can do so in a number of different ways. Right? It can do so by helping us sort of accept the change that's happening in our lives.
日常生活中的幸福感。换句话说，当绝对是这种情况时，即试图限制影响我们的创伤、改变外部世界，显然这确实有帮助，那是，这确实会产生积极的结果，同样也是这种情况，改变我们对这些创伤事件的反应，独立地也可以促进我们的幸福感。完全正确。并且它可以通过多种不同的方式做到这一点。对吧？它可以通过帮助我们某种程度上接受生活中正在发生的变化来做到这一点。
Doing so also gives us a sense of agency control. Right? We don't feel overwhelmed by the event. We don't feel like this event has somehow sort of taken over a sense of self has made us lose a sense of control over our lives. And it makes the event more manageable. So there was a time in your own life, Aranda, where you had to lean on your own capacity to exert secondary control. In other words, to exert control over your own, your own reactions, not the not the external world. Can you tell me about what happened in Sri Lanka in 2004? You were enrolled in college at the time, and the events that were unfolding
这样做也给了我们一种主动控制感。对吧？我们不会觉得被事件压倒。我们不会觉得这个事件不知何故接管了一种自我感，让我们失去了对生活的控制感。这使得事件更容易掌控。伊兰达，你自己的生活也曾有一段时间，你不得不依靠自己施加次级控制的能力。换句话说，对你自己的反应施加控制，而不是外部世界。你能告诉我 2004 年在斯里兰卡发生了什么吗？你当时正在上大学，正在发生的事件
were taking place thousands of miles away. Walk me through what happened. So I remember, I think it was Christmas in 2004. And at some point during the night, I got a message from my father saying that there had been an tsunami that hit Sri Lanka. And I remember that morning waking up and watching the news and seeing like these terrible scenes of people being swept through city centers by these waves of water.
发生在几千里之外。带我了解一下发生了什么。所以我想我记得那是 2004 年的圣诞节。在夜间的某个时候，我收到了我父亲的消息，说斯里兰卡发生了海啸。我记得那天早上醒来，看着新闻，看到人们被这些水波冲过市中心的那些可怕场景。
And he felt overwhelming because all the next few days, all these stories came out of the number of people who had been killed, the level of devastation on the eastern coast, on the southern coast, there was a train that was traveling down from Colombo to South of the country and the wave that came for tsunami engulfed the train and pulled it into the sea and then washed it back up a show, right, and many of these people on that train were lost. So there were all these terrible stories that were coming out and I, you know, felt completely helpless, right, I was worried about my my parents or thankfully they were not impacted that badly by the tsunami I was worried about the impact this would have on the friends I had there the people in the country and it wasn't
这让人感到难以承受，因为在接下来的几天里，所有这些关于死亡人数、东海岸和南海岸破坏程度的故事都出来了，有一列火车从科伦坡开往南部，海啸卷来的巨浪吞没了这列火车，把它拉进海里，然后又把它冲回海岸，对吧，火车上的许多人都失踪了。所以有所有这些可怕的故事流传出来，我，你知道，感到完全无助，对吧，我担心我的父母，谢天谢地，他们没有受到海啸的太大影响我在担心这对我在那里的朋友、国家里的人民会有什么影响，而且这并不是
Internet could do because I was like a college student and it's finally in Lancaster Pennsylvania So I remember thinking well, I can't do anything to fix it I just had to figure out how to manage with the fact that this terrible thing has happened and accept the well, I can't do anything to fix it. I just had to figure out how to manage with the fact that this terrible thing has happened and accept the fact that I can't do anybody right now. I will say that relying on secondary control at that point in time helps facilitate
互联网能做的事，因为我是一个大学生，最后在宾夕法尼亚州兰开斯特。所以我记得当时想，我无能为力，我只是不得不弄清楚如何面对发生这件可怕事情的事实，并接受嗯，我无能为力。我只是不得不弄清楚如何面对发生这件可怕事情的事实，并接受我目前谁也帮不了的事实。我要说的是，在那个时间点依赖次级控制有助于促进
a more sort of primary control response in the spring because in the spring of that year, I worked with some friends of mine to raise funds for people impacted by the tsunami and it ended up becoming one of the most meaningful experiences of my college career. And this is why I think these different control strategies can be so helpful because depending on where you are at the moment, depending on what you can and can't do in the moment, selectively utilizing these different strategies can be very helpful. And I do think in the case of tsunami, I was able to get to a place in the spring, but I was then able to exert
在春季做出更倾向于初级控制的反应，因为在那年春天，我和一些朋友一起为受海啸影响的人们筹集资金，这最终成为我大学生涯中最有意义的经历之一。这就是为什么我认为这些不同的控制策略会如此有用，因为取决于你当时所在的位置，取决于你当时能做什么和不能做什么，有选择地利用这些不同的策略会非常有用。我确实认为，在海啸的情况下，我能够在春天到达一个地方，然后我能够施加
primary control and do something that I hopefully was helpful to people in Sri Lanka. So another practice that's supported by your research is engaging in reflection on what we really care about and whether we're actually living out our values. Why would this be valuable and how would it work around that? Yes, so over the last few years I've been working with colleagues on DERP interventions to help people manage and recover from different types of adversity. And one insight that we include in interventions,
初级控制并做一些我希望对斯里兰卡人民有帮助的事情。因此，你的研究支持的另一种做法是对我们真正关心的事物以及我们是否真的在践行我们的价值观进行反思。为什么这会有价值，它又是如何运作的呢，伊兰达？是的，所以在过去的几年里，我一直在与同事合作开展 DERP 干预措施，以帮助人们管理和恢复不同类型的逆境。我们纳入干预措施的一个见解是，
and these are ideas that I've taken from other practices, like acceptance and commitment therapy, is the idea that one of the challenges when we're faced by adversity, of struggle, of suffering, is that it prevents us, dealing with the impact of that event, prevents us from living our lives the way we want to, or living our lives in light of the values that we care about.
这些是我从其他做法中汲取的想法，比如接管和承诺疗法，其核心思想是，当我们面对逆境、挣扎、痛苦时，挑战之一是它阻止了我们，处理该事件的影响阻止了我们按照我们想要的方式生活，或者根据我们关怀的价值观生活。
So one thing that we are trying to do in these interventions we're developing is to highlight for people who are taking part in this intervention the importance of their own values. So despite the fact they're going through challenges, despite the fact that there might be events outside the control that they're experiencing, what's important to them, what matters to them, and then how can they commit to behaviors that are consistent with those values? Because the idea is that even though you may be struggling or might be dealing with various
因此，我们在开发的这些干预措施中试图做的一件事，就是向参与这项干预措施的人强调他们自己的价值观的重要性。因此，尽管他们正在经历挑战，尽管他们可能会经历超出他们控制的事件，但什么对他们来说是重要的，什么对他们来说是紧要的，然后他们如何才能致力于符合这些价值观的行为？因为这个想法是，尽管你可能在挣扎，或者在逆境或苦难之后可能正在应对各种
challenges in the wake of adversity or in the wake of suffering that you can somehow separate out that struggle from who you are as a person and understand that you are not purely defined by your struggles, that you're also someone who has values and that you can still commit to that life despite the fact that you're simultaneously managing all these challenges that come from the aim of that adversity. I'm struck by the fact though that in some ways, this is a very different model than saying trauma and adversity make us into better versions
挑战，你可以把这种挣扎从你作为一个人的身份中某种程度上分离出来，并理解你不仅仅是由你的挣扎定义的，你也是一个有价值观的人，尽管你同时在应对来自该逆境目标的所有这些挑战，你仍然可以致力于那种生活。然而，让我震惊的是，在某些方面，这与“创伤和逆境使我们成为更好版本的自己”这种说法是一个非常不同的模型。这实际上是在说，创伤和逆境帮助我们发现了内心深处原本的自己。
of ourselves. This is really saying trauma and adversity help us discover who we really always were on the inside. I think that's exactly right. And I think one problem with current research in post-traumatic growth is the term itself. So there are two assumptions baked into the phrase post-traumatic growth, right? One is that trauma is needed for you to grow, but also that you are going to become a better person. And that is a much more simplistic understanding of what happens to you when
我认为这完全正确。我认为当前创伤后成长研究的一个问题是这个术语本身。因此，创伤后成长这个短语中内置了两个假设，对吧？一个是成长需要创伤，另一个是你将成为一个更好的人。对于当你经历重大生活事件时会发生在你身上的事情，这是一种更简单的理解，我认为这才是大多数人的情况。我认为人们很有可能变得更有同理心。他们可以对自己的生活有极大的洞察力。他们可以再次致力于自己的价值观。但我们应该足够敏感，不能说这意味着创伤或逆境是值得的。一个人可以变得富有同情心，
you experience a major life event that I think is the case for most people. I think it's quite likely that people can become more compassionate. They can get great insight into their own lives. They can commit to their values again. But we should be sensitive enough not to say that that means that the trauma or the adversity was worth it. Someone could become compassionate,
一个人可以变得更明智，一个人可以致力于践行自己的价值观，却依然在心理健康或其他生活方式上面临重大的挑战。伊兰达发现，他自己的生活反映了他在研究中发现的内容。他越是反思自己的价值观，就越发现自己将自己成长的经历与其他人境况联系在一起。2019 年新西兰两座清真寺遭到袭击的消息传出时，顿悟的时刻到来了。我最终熬夜到凌晨四点或五点，看着事件实时展开
someone could become wiser, someone could commit to living their values, and still experience significant challenges in their mental health or in other means of their life. Iranda found that his own life reflected what he was finding in his research. The more he reflected on his values, the more he found himself connecting his own experiences growing up with those of people in other contexts. One moment of epiphany came when news broke in 2019 of attacks on two mosques in New Zealand. I end up staying up to like four or five in the morning, watching the events unfold in
实时展开。我有这种强烈的实时展开的事件。我有一种强烈的本能反应，对吧，当我听到这个枪手走进清真寺，你知道，不加区分地杀害了所有人时。你知道，我的想法是，哦，你知道，如果有人这样决定袭击
real time. And I had this sort of strong the events unfold in real time. And I had this sort of strong visceral reaction, right, when I heard about this gunman who had gone into a mosque and, you know, was indiscriminately killing all these people. You know, my thought was that, oh, you know, if there was someone like that that decided to attack
在北卡罗来纳州，对吧？这是第一次让我清楚地认识到，你知道，我的身份，对吧，作为一个南亚血统的美国移民，在这个环境中可能会卷入这样的事件。回顾过去，这确实标志着我开始思考自己方式的转变。我对基督城袭击事件的反应，真正凸显了对吧，这感觉像是一件可以对我和我做的事，这是我在某种程度上感受到的，对吧？
in North Carolina, right? And it was one of the first times where we can clear to me that, you know, my identity, right, being an American immigrant of South Asian origin who in this context could be caught up in an event like that. And I was looking back on that, that did mark a shift in how I started to think about myself. And my reaction to the Christ Church attack, really highlighted the right, this feels like something that could be done to me, this is something that I feel at some level, right?
我觉得我受到了影响，对吧？即使我没有直接的联系，对吧？但我有一种本能的感觉，发生在他们身上的事，在另一个世界里，在不同的情况下，潜在地可能会发生在我身上。这与你对 9-11 的反应非常不同，9-11 某种程度上是一种疏离的反应，或者甚至是一种“这真的不影响我”或“这与我无关”的反应。
I felt I was being impacted by, right? Even though I don't have a direct connection, right? But I had this visceral sense that what was happened to them could potentially in a different world, in the different circumstances happened to me. And that's very different than your reaction to 9-11, which was in some extent a reaction of detachment or a reaction even of like this doesn't really affect me or this isn't about this does not concern me.
完全正确。我认为这凸显了一个重要的教训，关于我们如何处理逆境，我们如何处理逆境，我们如何处理创伤。所以我并不怀疑这种疏离感、这种将创伤和逆境常态化的感觉，当你在那种环境中时是有用的。但它也伴随着代价，尤其是当你不再生活在那种环境中时。我认为回想我来到美国以来的生活，对吧？我感到震惊的是，随着我从斯里兰卡的生活中获得更多的距离，我变得更加意识到，对吧？这种常态化是多么无处不在。
Exactly. And I think this highlighted the important lesson about how we deal with adversity, how we deal with adversity, how we deal with trauma. So I don't doubt that the sense of detachment, the sense of normalizing trauma and adversity can be useful when you are in that context. But it also comes with costs, especially when you don't live in that context anymore. And I think thinking back over my life since coming to the US, right? I'm struck by how, as I've gained more distance for my life in Sri Lanka, I become more aware, right? Of just how ubiquitous this normalization was.
而且，你知道，我从心理健康的角度理解它的好处，但我也看到了代价。创伤可以产生生长的另一个领域。同样，这种成长与“打不倒你的会使你更强大”的陈词滥调截然不同。心理学家迪恩·西蒙顿（Dean Simonton）探讨了挫折、逆境的经历、
And, you know, I understand the benefits of it from a mental head perspective, but I also see the cost. There is one other domain where trauma can produce growth. Again, this growth looks very different than the what doesn't kill you makes you stronger trope. The psychologist Dean Simonton has explored the correlation between the experience of setbacks, adversity,
作为一个局外人，以及创造力之间的相关性。我认为这里的核心观点，我认为这也是西蒙顿写过的一些东西，那就是，人们经历任何类型的非寻常的、意想不到的事件的程度，会推动人们从非正常的视角体验世界。这种事情某种程度上使这些人能够从边缘思考世界。并且在你经历不寻常事件、意想不到事件的程度上，这使你能够某种程度上对不同的方式保持开放
and being an outsider, and creativity. I think the key idea here, and I think this is something that Simonton has written about, is that to the extent to which people experience any type of unusual, unexpected event that pushes people to experience the world from a non-normal perspective. That sort of enables these people to think about the world from the margins. And to the extent to which you experience unusual events, unexpected events, that enables you to sort of be open to different ways
思考世界和理解人类经验。我的意思是，我在想非凡的艺术似乎经常从苦难中涌现出来。例如，当你看着文森特·梵高（Vincent Van Gogh）华丽的绘画，或者贝多芬的音乐时，你在这些艺术家身上听到了你自己的研究和发现的回响吗？回到这个佛教观点，生命的根本特征是苦难。
of thinking about the world and understanding human experience. I mean, I'm thinking about how extraordinary art often seems to emerge out of suffering. When you look at the gorgeous paintings of Vincent Van Gogh, for example, of the music of Beethoven, do you hear echoes in those artists of your own research and findings? Going back to this Buddhist idea, that fundamental characteristic of life is suffering.
成为人类的部分意义在于找到一种方法来面对和管理我们对苦难和逆境的体验。这种观点在弗里达·卡洛（Frida Kahlo）和文森特·梵高（Vincent Van Gogh）等某些艺术家的作品中表现得非常强烈。我的意思是，我想到了贝多芬，他在完全失聪的时候写下了他最著名的一些音乐。这似乎非同寻常，这是另一种不同的超级英雄陈词滥调。你知道，这不是开发某种新技能，而是真正加倍投入你内心的东西。我认为这完全正确，你知道，当梵高创作出伟大的艺术品时，你知道，生活在相当大的心理痛苦中，
That part of what it means to be human is to find a way to confront and manage our experience of suffering and adversity. That view comes out very strongly in the work of a certain artists like Frida Kahlo and Vincent Van Gogh. I mean I'm thinking about Beethoven who wrote some of his most famous music when he was completely deaf. That just seems extraordinary and it's a different kind of superhero trope. You know, it's not developing some new skill but really doubling down on what it is that you have inside of you. I think that's exactly right and you know, when thing when go produce great artwork, right, and you know lived in considerable psychological pain,
弗里达·卡洛（Frida Kahlo）创作了伟大的艺术品，生活在相当大的身体痛苦中，你知道，贝多芬在失聪的过程中创作了这首美妙的音乐。因此，作为一名艺术欣赏者，我可能会说，好吧，是的，他遭受了许多这些伟大艺术家的痛苦，但看看他们给了我们什么。我认为我的倾向可能是专注于艺术品，专注于由于这种经历而产生的成果。我认为这是一个有趣的哲学问题，
Frida Kahlo, produce great artwork and lived in considerable physical pain, and you know, Beethoven produced this wonderful music as he was going in death. So, as an appreciative art, I might be kind of saying, well, yes, he suffered many of these great artists suffered, but look what they gave us. And I think my inclination might be to focus on the art work, on what was produced as a result of that experience. I think it's an interesting philosophical question,
艺术的创作是否值得付出痛苦和代价，对吧？我认为我们在思考我们所经历的变化、发现逆境时遇到的挑战之一，纯粹以积极的或消极的术语来看待，我认为它掩盖了这样一个事实，即我们可以对逆境有复杂的反应，它可以同时导致积极和消极的结果。并且我认为只要我们对此诚实，并且我们对这样一个事实诚实，即在某些情况下，人们可以变得更有同理心或者他们可以提高创造力，对吧？
whether the production of art is worth the pain and suffering, right? I think one of the challenges we're thinking about, the changes we experience, find adversity, purely in positive terms or in negative terms, I think obscures the fact that we can have a complex reaction to adversity and it can lead to positive and negative outcomes simultaneously. And I think as long as we're honest about that, and we're honest about the fact that, yes, under some circumstances, people can grow more compassionate or they can increase their creativity, right?
但这同时也伴随着其他可能没那么积极的变化。所以也许你会继续与你的心理健康作斗争，或者你在其他领域可能会经历消极的变化。我认为展望未来，特别是由于围绕创伤后生长的文化叙事如此强烈，这种想法，特别是在美国，并且在世界其他地方越来越多，即糟糕的事件是生长的机会。也许采取稍微更谦逊的观点并说，好吧，你知道，逆境和
But also, that is accompanied by other changes that may not be as positive. So maybe you will continue to struggle with your mental health, or you might experience negative changes in other domains. I think going forward, especially because the cultural narrative around post-traumatic growth is so strong, this idea, especially in the United States, and increasingly in other parts of the world, that bad events are an opportunity for growth. Maybe taking a slightly more humble view and saying, well, you know, adversity and
挣扎是坏事，你知道，这些事件是我们不希望发生在其他人身上的明确事件。同时，它们可以以不同的方式改变人们。其中一些变化可能是积极的，其中一些可能是消极的。我认为在我们对某人的生活与事件发生前相比是否总体上更好做出断言之前，把所有这些变化放在一起看是很重要的。伊兰达·乔伊·维克拉马（Iranda Joy Wickramma）是维克森林大学的心理学家。伊兰达，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。
struggle are bad things, you know, those events are clear events that we would not want to wish in other people. And at the same time, they can change people in different ways. And some of those changes can be positive, some of them can be negative. And I think it's important for us to look at all those changes together before we make claims about whether someone's life is better overall compared to before the event. Miranda Joy Wichramma is a psychologist at Wake Forest University. Miranda, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
非常感谢邀请我。嗨。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯蒂安·王（Christian Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。
Thank you so much for having me. Hi. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
接下来是我们的“治愈 2.0”系列节目，这是为我们的播客订阅用户准备的独家单集节目《隐藏的大脑 Plus》（Hidden Brain Plus）。我们探讨了关于人们在经历创伤或悲剧后如何恢复的令人惊奇且令人欣慰的研究。该节目即将登陆《隐藏的大脑 Plus》。您可以收听该单集并免费试用《隐藏的大脑 Plus》。只需在苹果播客中找到《隐藏的大脑》，然后点击“免费试用”按钮即可开始您的试用。或者访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。
Up next in our Healing 2.0 series, an exclusive episode for listeners to our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. We look at surprising and reassuring research about how people recover when they've experienced trauma or tragedy. That's coming soon on Hidden Brain Plus. You can listen to that episode and try Hidden Brain Plus for free. Just find Hidden Brain and Apple podcasts and click the Try Free button to begin your trial. Or go to apple.co slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon.
你这个单集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
朦芙节目冂故表腹。点击文本中的任意叵子可以留下评论。